中大膽周报
欢迎收看中大膽周报
中大膽周报公开版237集
我们在录这一集的同时
快要迎来的一个东西叫做
清明节廉价
其实因为去年的清明节廉价
大家真的吓坏了
廉价后变盘
而且是因为对等关税往下杀
那最近台股的气氛
说实话又比较诡诀
每一站是没有办法平复的关系
会不会中大胆要提出一些
让大家觉得要不要警戒的事情呢
好的
季底已经快到了
只剩下两天的时间
那我相信也有很多的投资朋友
也跟你刚刚所讲的
哎呦去年也这样子
然后呢放完假之后就变个样子
所以呢
与其这样子就让自己
干脆就放个一个礼拜的假
放一个礼拜的假
意思是说钱不赚也没关系嘛
对不对
就是这几个假日就散了这样
还是变成中性的角度
所以我想今天我们再跟大家来谈一下
我对清明节这部分的一个筹资筹率的一个看法
那我们现在看一下整个大盘来看
现在已经到三月底
我记得三月初的时候市场上讲会过四万点
到月底的时候会不会是三万点
怎么七个月就马上180度转变
当然因为最主要是在于说
这个有美一战争的部分
不过原则上我们可以发现到
在这波的当中
我们之前提到过
短线的支撑32500点
然后中线支撑32500
你会发现到3月9号
那一波的最低点就是在32500以下
也就是说如果你有听话
那天买的话
应该买到这一波当中相对低
那32500呢
在这个礼拜当中最低是32434
也就是说
再来到32500点以下
你会发现
还就有一只手出来了
所以你要发现礼拜五的时候
大节的时候
我看这次会不会破32500
发现到32600点
就已经有人很知道规则了
所以最后收牌就收一个角
所以我跟各位讲的指数
不是我随便乱蒙的
不是乱讲的
而且那个动物场会有一段时间
发现它很有效
因为在对指数研判
我是很小心谨慎
那这个礼拜对整个大盘的看法
我想
目前还是一样
下个礼拜还是看法
在32500点附近会有支撑
那中线支撑
会是在前六周的红K线
大概就是31956
大概3万2
那微谷这波会整理到
七明节第八周的时间
在做观察
从图上各位可以发现到
这波从35579点拉回到现在
如果要用这样时间来看
我不觉得七明节前
市场上的这些的
做手会在这边抢工
因为工不了几天又长假
所以呢我认为说他就
跟着这个川普的动作是一样继续从五天延十天延到4月6号反正他战事延火嘛股市也跟着延火延长时间大家就是把时间延长
这样子
大家都同步去观察
那我认为说
如果大盘大跌下来的话
我想还是
都是一个
拉回的好机会
布局好机会
所以现在这个大盘就是
大跌的时候你才买
大涨的时候就千万不能买
我看这礼拜好像有成绩差一点
快到3万4
又踩煞车
所以你看三万四就一定有点会
有压力
又有压力
好
那投资朋友们
你会发现这段时间
市场上
到底说要怎么做
我们不妨先从几个角度来看
首先来看一下
外资常追高杀低
我常想
如果你跟着外资做
你会赚钱我就扶着你
不太可能
为什么
除非你有衍生性商品
还有大额的资金
你可以这样跟他一样
练性
这样子
不然你會發現
我們這樣同圖上
你會發現
外資就長期就是
買在高檔
然後燒在低檔
我記得上次有跟各位講的一個版本就是
五日線之上外資就是在買方
五日線破他就在賣方
你會發現到現在
如果同圖上你這樣看看
如果我不考慮衍生性商品
只看現貨
他基本上都是買在高檔
當然有時候為了拉高
所以想
如果想看外資的動作
你會發現
你真的搞不懂他在
他在想什麼
那投信呢
低階高出
投信就比较像我们要讲
像我们要赚钱的
你就有来
你敢来到3万2千5百点
或3万2
投信就大量的去做布局动作
但你会发现
投信确实是
真的是说到做到
他从2月份以来到现在
基本上都是占买方
但我觉得他是比较适合投资人做法
他有点跟外资相反
你要发现
他之前买比较多
他会都是在破月线以下
然后站上月线
他这买的比较少
刚好是外资是相反的
那我觉得最近我这礼拜
下礼拜的盘我比较花一个观望盘
观望吗
因为也才四个交易日
因为外资他基本上就占卖方
我看现在他已经卖8000多亿了
三月已经创下史上最多单月卖超了
那投信的部分虽然是买方
但是我也不确定他现在买
是因为第一季要做账了
还是看好后面的后市
我没把握
所以我比較掛問號
因為這兩天他也在做一些作帳動作
那另外來講就是市場上會有一群先知先決的
跟後知後決
我們先來看一下
這波當中一月初的時候先知先決的買盤
我把它叫做先買
簡稱叫先買
這樣比較不會落口
先買先知先決的人
後知後決的人買進的叫後買
後買
這樣很好記
你會發現一月份那些先買的人
印度买上去
那投信那时候不是
奇怪怎么突然一直一口气涨上去
后来才发现
可能就是来自于一些比较属于稳定的那些受险等等资金的所以你会发现那一波来讲是先买的然后呢先卖的然后后面买的
然后又让股价又压回来
到了今年2月过年前的时候
先买的那一瓶买进去
然后呢到了今年3月初的时候
先买的先卖
后买的买进
这样很好记
那就是
其实我发现你没有发现
我好像站在先买的角度
比较容易对不对
早买早享受
所以这波的三月份
我们有一直跟大家提到过
会甩一叫一次
确实甩很多
那这波曾经来到3月9号的时候
那个先买的又出来了
然后到了这个34,000的时候
先买的先卖
后买的跟上买
那当然如果你有看我们的YouTube
你应该会发现
你应该是常常站在先买那一方
那但是呢
现在这个点
我不知道这波的先决
先买的人
他是要先
他在这波来到32500点
是真的在那先买的
还是呢
先卖
就是先前的3万4的时候
还是先做卖方
我也不太确定
是
因为最近的成交量有萎缩
萎缩的背后因素我不知道
因为每个人的
不买股票的原因有很多
没办法去猜测
但是我只是说
从今年1月份到现在
这个先买过的是后买的
到目前看起来这个先买的部分
我比较挂一个问号
那融资户呢
今年以来我们常发现
它都是一个市场上的指标性
我说这个融资不太像是
一般的散物融资
比较算是聪明的融资
你会发现聪明的融资早在
这礼拜当中有连续三天
卖股票
你说那是因为被吓到的
我不认为
因为它破月线
有一些大户高手
他知道不对
先把融资融资买的股票
先把它抽回来
所以这部分连续三天的下
这个融资减少
我表示
我认为这是叫聪明的融资
为什么
他已经在因后面连续长假到来的
这个所谓的一些所谓的买盘的萎缩
所以他先把融资的资金
先做抽回来动作
所以你会发现
虽然后来有一天又有增加
但是后来融资又再出现减少
对
一般融资
责户融资不会这么
没那么灵活
不会那么灵活
所以我觉得这个比较算是聪明的融资
他先退出场观望
所以呢清明节的做法
我大概会先跟各位来讲一下
我的想法就是
我原本规划今年第一次的中期修正的位置图的时间
就是差不多在四月左右
这时间点
那我不确定是不是因为美英战争提早
让这个拉回的动作
提早在三月初拉回来
那我也不确定头信是不是
因为记底做完账就出场
所以这边我只画个问号那怎么办就3400到34500点你就多减码然后32000到32500就多加码你是2000点
但是你要发现
所以两个礼拜
如果按照我的模式操作
你不是确实是
来到34000附近
你就发现你减码
你看到跌了1000多点
你就发现你买进
好像又有利润空间
那干嘛
等待这个季线的支撑
也上量来到这个位置
我认为在亲密节之前
你持股大概降到七成或七成以下
等待拉回你再去做提高比重
我还是可以强调
对台股操作这个指数
你要有中心思想
你不能变来变去
不然你很难决定是否要进场
为什么
当然有人会觉得说
你三万点
搞不好会跌破三万点
或两万多点
那你这时候来到三万两千五百点
你就不敢要进场
所以我觉得
投资人可能要有一个
先有一个定想法
当然
当然这个大盘指数还会随着整个
美国战争或GDP的成长变化去改变
但是不要说马上
一个礼拜完之后马上就看到3万点以下
一个礼拜之后马上看到4万点
这样你根本永远都不晓得要怎么做进场
原点上我现在还是觉得3万2
这边是一个很重要
比如我们刚刚看那个图
其实如果那条上升趋势线
中期的上升趋势线
在清明节节后
应该差不多就要决定方向
那我持股策略呢
就这两天啊
我建议你就会买台积电
或高股息殖利率
还有另类可供可类的个股
我会在我们的影山板当中来做介绍
跌的时候你也会开心
但不是高股息殖利率的个股
我待会再跟各位讲
那我觉得台积电是因为
他即将在4月中开这个法售会
所以呢如果你真的不确定的话
我觉得买台积电或高股息殖利率
或一个可供可费的个股
我觉得尽管是我项目会建议把持股比重降低
多准备一些现金
但是呢
如果你不做这样动作
你可以把资金移到我刚才讲的这些的几个方向去
好其实台积电这一波也是受到影响
一直被压抑常常出现1800块钱
甚至还有出现过更低
在夜盘这个提货的部分
所以现在它算是一个很好的防御型标的
但是呢如果您喜欢个股呢
那当然中大版在我们的隐藏版
连我都有点在想说
什么东西叫做叠了会很高兴
而且还不是高值利率的
对
诶好像猜谜
所以有兴趣订阅的朋友
记得到我们电脑版首页
赵华的头像旁边
有一个加入的按钮
把它按下去
手机订阅的朋友
我会把订阅的连结
放在留言的第一则
还是要叮咛一下
如果您是用苹果手机的话
苹果手机它会收一个额外的
所谓的他们的服务费用
所以都好用電腦來做訂閱
如果用電腦做訂閱
只要帳號跟手機是同一個的話
都是可以收看的
那我們就VIP見囉